I said The Blueprint you know and
everyone for me a lot of artists won't
be using social media to promote their
music and connect with their fans Soulja
Boy gets real with et about his role in
pop culture ahead of his big comeback
[Music]
you have really created the blueprint
for the way that artists handle social
media and just handle music in general I
know that your interview and viral but
just talk to me about this big comeback
that you have going on so I'm just
working man and I'm focused you know
I've been working hard on my craft over
the years I got way better with my music
and you were I did set the blueprint for
these new artists you see coming out
today as far as the me goes cheeky
little beer is the kid
I set the blueprint you know and every
wasn't for me a lot of artists when we
using social media to promote their
music and connect with their fans so
it's a beautiful thing now you see
Spotify Apple music and streaming I'm
the reason for that you know I'm saying
I started there I was the first rap on
YouTube and on everything that I was
doing ten years ago is basically the
blueprint or the that the labels are
following with all the new artists so
how are you gonna come out bigger and
better with your new music tell us what
the vibe is of it man I got I got Chief
Keef on my album ASAP ferg I got a
little baby I got trippy Reyes Whaley
runny J Tim Allen man this goes on Nikki
I mean it man Nicki Minaj is going on
tour this summer I shot the lava nation
it's gonna be a good year 2019
Superman now you know one thing that
years ago we were all doing every dance
move that you had is there anything that
you think you're gonna have in the works
with your new album
any dance move that could go with it I
got a new dance coming out real soon
yeah i'ma dropping in my next music
video so y'all stay tuned before I let
you go what are the different reaction
been to all these memes and everything
with a Drake and all that how do you
feel you think that Dre nah man
man Drake just talk not so long ago like
yesterday on Instagram DM and we just
chopped it up and just it's funny
because he even hit me call me I'm like
oh you damn me I'm like what's up
drinking like Dre I'm like wow I got
Drake this and that's how I knew it was
viral one last thing is there anyone
that's the best Best New Artist
nominated that you are rooting for
Georgia Smith there a reason why and you
know I just want to see your way you
know